non
bonjour et bienvenue à strasbourg au
coeur du parlement européen pour cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo quel
est le bon rythme scolaire pour les
petits européens la réforme est en cours
en france
reportage en bavière où l'on fait la
classe le matin comme le veut la
tradition allemande mais d'abord
l'actualité la sphère cahuzac a remis la
question des paradis fiscaux au coeur du
débat européen
alors à quand la fin du secret bancaire
c'est la question de la semaine
on l'avait presque oublié ce dossier
le secret bancaire ce sacro-saint secret
bancaire
il faut dire que ces cachotteries sont
bien gardés au sein de l'union
comment il y à de l'évasion fiscale dans
l'europe quoi il existe des paradis
fiscaux sur le continent vous plaisantez
chypre luxembourg l'autriche les îles de
jersey de guernesey et la suisse depuis
les rebondissements de la sphère cahuzac
les ministres de l'économie de l'union
tente de convaincre ses mauvais élèves
de mettre à disposition les informations
bancaires de leurs clients à simple si
le luxembourg a fait un pas l'autriche
freine toujours mais même les états unis
ont fait plier les banques et mis en
place un système de mesure qui permet de
lutter contre l'exil mais pourtant 2009
nicolas sarkozy avait aboli les paradis
fiscaux non alors c'est pour quand cette
fin du secret bancaire
et nous voilà de retour au parlement
européen à strasbourg alors quand la fin
du secret bancaire c'est un petit peu le
serpent de mer dont on entend parler
depuis des années pour en parler yannick
jadot nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe des verts et
surtout vice président de la commission
commerce international alors finalement
on nous l'avait promis avec sarkozy en
2009 promis c'est la fin des paradis
fiscaux du secret bancaire
on nous large ou encore une fois
aujourd'hui avec françois hollande
est ce que vous le croyez cette fois le
président république je crois surtout
que les conditions ont changé c'est vrai
que c'est ce sont des promesses qui sont
mis à chaque fois qu'un scandale on
raconte ça aux citoyens du monde entier
étienne monde fait pas grand chose mais
là c'est vrai que les conditions
changent et 1
il ya une nécessité économique les états
sont totalement essorer financièrement
donc les états ont besoin de recettes
fiscales et la crise sociale la crise
économique fait que le consentement à
l'impôt est de plus en plus faibles donc
l'évasion fiscale la fraude fiscale sont
beaucoup moins tolérées qu'avant on a
besoin des rucks on enlève à 25
milliards de capitaux placés à
l'étranger qui échappent complètement
aux états sur la france on est même
jusqu'à 40 50 milliards selon les
estimations
et au niveau européen on est à mille
milliards donc c'est considérable la
perte en recettes fiscales liées à la
fraude fiscale comme à l'optimisation
fiscale
le deuxième élément c'est évidemment
l'élément politique la sphère cahuzac a
fait monter le populisme en france comme
d'autres à faire dans d'autres pays
européens il ya nécessité d'apporter des
règles et de dire que finalement même
les plus riches doivent répondre à la
règle commune
et puis dernier élément qui peut être
finalement le plus important c'est que
les états unis ont fait la démonstration
qu'on peut exiger de paradis fiscaux là
où il ya le secret bancaire qui est
entretenue on peut exiger les
informations pour l'administration
fiscale et à partir du moment où les
états unis
sont en train d'obtenir du luxembourg de
la suisse et d'autres pays européens ou
non européens les informations fiscales
la fin de la transe delà de la deûle à
l'opacité bancaire et bien évidemment
les pays européens n'ont plus qu'à
s'aligner à suivre le chemin ouvert par
les états unis à dire au luxembourg à
l'autriche à la suisse vous faites avec
les états unis
donc vous devez le faire avec nous
parler de la loi fatca qui a été votée
aux états unis effectivement donc ça
oblige en fait les pays étrangers les
banques à donner les informations
bancaires des ressortissants américains
mais on voit bien qu en europe là il ya
eu un ecofin donc un conseil des
ministres des finances européens que
l'autriche bloc et tout le monde pointe
la city sale angleterre avec les îles de
jersey de guernesey finalement
on a déjà des paradis fiscaux dans
l'europe parce qu'on devrait pas
nettoyer notre linge sale en famille
avant d'aller pointer le doigt sur les
étrangers c'est évident c'était donc la
mission première des européens
aujourd'hui c'est le balayer devant leur
porte
la france chypre est un paradis fiscal
monétaire on sait qu'on a un certain
territoire notamment dans les antilles
ou ailleurs qui servent de paradis
fiscaux qui servent à l'évasion fiscale
est évidemment l'ensemble des pays
européens est concerné mais ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya on n'a
jamais eu aussi une hausse une fenêtre
aussi ouverte en termes de modification
des réglementations on voit bien qu'au
parlement européen on entraîneront à on
a voté sur les bonus des banquiers on
voit de plus en plus sur les échanges
d'informations
ce qu'il faut c'est que le cadre qu'on
va poser qui doit porter la fin des
paradis fiscaux
c'est un cadre qui doit aller jusqu'au
bout du processus mais c'est quand on
voit dit pardon tout ce qu'on avait dit
en 2009 avec nicolas sarkozy vienne g8
via le g20
on n'avait pas eu facteurs on n'avait
pas eu la démonstration qui suffit de
volonté politique pour y arriver et que
maintenant l'égalité traitement d'une
certaine façon au niveau des états fait
que la france peut demander au
luxembourg la même chose que lui demande
les états unis alex qui fait c'était en
revanche là où faut vraiment travailler
sérieusement c'est qu'il suffit pas
simplement de savoir quels sont les
comptes des parle de personnes physiques
placés dans ces banques
on sait bien que tout le jeu des paradis
fiscaux c'est d'orchestrer des sociétés
écrans des trusts des fondations il
essayait en diamant où on ne sait plus
qui bénéficient de ces paradis fiscaux
il ya eu un reportage dans un même de
madère français cette semaine qu'ils
monteraient à combien tapie était devenu
maître dans le montage de sociétés
écrans donc on il faut absolument que
cette transparence se fassent à la fois
sur l'ensemble des produits financiers
qui sont placés dans des comptes à
l'étranger
et puis que ça touche pas simplement les
personnes physiques mais évidemment
aussi les personnes morales toutes ces
sociétés écrans
son qui forment le trou noir aujourd'hui
de la finance internationale oui et qui
paye 3 % d'impôt contre 33 1/3 pour les
pme et je ne sais pas les moyens
d'accueillir un élément aussi qui fait
bouger le royaume uni alors le royaume
uni ont cessé spécialisée dans la
finance
il a fait la financiarisation de
l'économie parce qu'ils ont ils ont tué
leur industrie ils ont tué leur
agriculture
donc ils ont toujours eu besoin de faire
du dumping fiscal pour attirer les
sociétés chez eux mais en même temps ils
s'aperçoivent que des grandes des grands
groupes multinationaux qui sont placés à
londres ne paient quasiment pas d'impôt
chez eux donc au finish le fait
d'attirer des sociétés ne se traduit pas
forcément par des recettes fiscales
supplémentaires puisque comme vous le
dites
en france les grands groupes
multinationaux notamment ceux du cac 40
payent à peu près 8 % d'impôts alors que
les petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est plutôt 30 33 et en grande bretagne
c'est encore moi et ça c'est j'allais
dire le deuxième grand chantier à côté
de celui des paradis fiscaux c'est tout
l'évasion fiscale légale
tous ces deux par dieu tout toutes ces
sociétés anonymes ces sociétés privées
qui quitte un territoire pour aller sur
un autre territoire européen
parce qu'il ya du dumping fiscal m'en
voulais faire revenir à ce qu'il faut
voter aujourd'hui une amnistie pour
faire revenir ces capitaux parce
qu'après tout ils se sont cachés ils
disent on va prendre 60% d'imposition
sur le scond aura rapatriés est-ce qu'il
faut voter aujourd'hui une amnistie
fiscale pour permettre de rapatrier ses
capitaux je crois pas l'amnistié fiscale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le fait que
l'europe mais pas de politique fiscale
commune fait que ceux qui peuvent bouger
les acteurs les plus mobiles que ce soit
les grandes sociétés ou les plus hauts
revenus mais il se hisse s'expatrie en
belgique et s'expatrie en irlande en
grande-bretagne aux pays-bas ou ailleurs
donc je pense pas qu'ils aient
aujourd'hui une telle citoyenneté ou un
tel sentiment de citoyenneté qui vont
dire voilà j'ai pas bien fait j'ai fait
voilà on a tous à pardon
bon ma faute morale j'irai à la con
faire une confession à l'intérieur voilà
je ferai une confession à la télé et
tout ira bien non ce qu'il faut et ça
c'est la responsabilité des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens
c'est d'avoir d'aller vers
l'harmonisation fiscale européenne pour
éviter ce dumping cette course au moins
disant fiscal qui tue nos dépenses en
matière d'école en matière de santé en
matière d'investissement et c'est pour
ça que nous nous proposons les
écologistes un taux harmonisé minimum de
25% sur les sociétés après aux
différents états d'en rajouter s'ils
veulent mais au moins 25% comme ça on
arrête cette course à l'échalote entre
ou sur la le dumping fiscal qui tue nos
démocraties aujourd'hui un autre dossier
donc qu'on suivra bien entendu merci
beaucoup et yannick jadot d'avoir été
parmi nous vous l'avez dit le grand
dossier qui nous a occupés ces derniers
temps c'est cahuzac et notamment la
question de la transparence puisque la
plupart des ministres enfin les
ministres français en fait avant
peut-être les députés ont déclaré leur
patrimoine
et cela bien entendu a fait causer nos
voisins européens un petit tour des
télévisions étrangères c'est avec
aurélie la face transparence et
moralisation deux maîtres mots pour un
grand déballage au gouvernement le
patrimoine des ministres français
qu'elle a une télévision eurocast
ministre président jean marc ayrault
affiche un million et demi de patrimoine
autres riches du gouvernement michèle
delaunay la ministre déléguée aux
personnes âgées avec 5 millions quatre
cent mille euros et marisol touraine aux
ministres aux affaires sociales
avec un million quatre cent mille euros
étaient les plus pauvres sur la ministre
de l'environnement cécile duflot avec
une maison dans les landes une twingo et
une 4l suis la ministre de la culture
aurélie filippetti avec un appartement
de 70 m² à paris à l'étalagé de richesse
vient obligé pour redresser la côte de
françois hollande
selon ce journaliste britannique le
modèle de modestie prôné par françois
hollande avant l'élection présidentielle
cette idée d'une société plus juste a
été mise à mal par les mensonges et des
excès d' sont annie
du budget la cote de popularité du
président était déjà basses elle est
désormais catastrophique
en belgique les élus net là et j'ai
alors 7 à 13 ans mais ils ne leur ont
pas alors ce qu'on est français amène
les médias à poser la question là
faut-il aller plus loin
imposer à tout le monde de rendre cela
public pourquoi
à moins de le faire alors pour
l'ensemble des citoyens
les joueurs de football les artistes
tous les citoyens alors mais là vous
avez l'administration fiscale le
contrôle des revenus
il y a dans cette lettre qui est déposée
auprès de la cour des comptes
des éléments qui ont trait à la vie
privée et c'est justement un journaliste
belge qui nous a rejoint pour évoquer
cette question de la transparence en
france maroun labaki bonjour vous êtes
donc journaliste au soir quotidien de
référence en belgique
est-ce que comment est ce que vous voyez
en fait ce grand débat qu'on a en france
sur cette question de la transparence
est ce que pour vous c'est une
démocratie paparazzi on va écouter nous
on voit ça surtout je crois qu'on voit
les choses pour ce qu'elles sont c'est à
dire françois hollande
était en très mauvaise posture politique
il devait trouver quelque chose dans la
précipitation et voilà donc c'est une
opération de com est question selon-vous
ya pas de nom je crois qu'il faut faire
il faut poser la question de la
transparence c'est évidemment légitime
mais ça s'est fait quand même dans une
extraordinaire précipitation donc je
veux dire on peut pas dire qu'on a
beaucoup réfléchi sur les conséquences
associations donc on fait quelque chose
qui est de nature à calmer un peu
l'opinion publique voilà alors après on
peut d matri l'amant du bien fondé de
jusqu'où on va etc
mais au fond c'est une opération de
communication politique et ça nous
intéresse beaucoup parce que en belgique
nous suivons de très près la politique
française alors justement belgique
comment ça se passe vous aussi vos élus
déclarent en fait leur patrimoine
oui il déclare c'est à dire que ce qui
est public ce sont tous les mandats dont
ils disposent donc rémunérés ou pas ça
doit être mis à jour tous les ans et
c'est public et donc tous les tous les
élus à tous les niveaux sont tenus de le
faire donc c'est leur salaire qui est
déclaré finalement oui et l'arrivisme de
rémunération dans les conseils
d'administration dans les
intercommunales enfin dans toutes sortes
de structures dans mais leur patrimoine
n'est pas rendu public
alors non le patrimoine est déclarée
mais ça se fait sous scellés et donc
ceux déposés à la cour des comptes en
cas de problème si un juge d'instruction
veut y avoir accès il va regarder
et puis voilà cela dit ça s'est jamais
passé
donc vous avez une classe politique
exemplaire bon en tout cas en tout cas
ceux qui ceux qui trichent le font bien
aussi il faut réfléchir à cet aspect des
choses
on a beau demander la transparence et
publié ce 6 publié cela celui qui triche
et qui a une société offshore il va pas
mettre dans cette île dans un petit
enclos et léger une chose j'étais là
effectivement c'est du déclaratif donc
si vous voulez continue de cacher que
vous avez un compte en suisse ou à
singapour
rien ne vois là mais est-ce qu'on doit
aller vers plus de transparence certains
en france disent que c'est une
démocratie pas paradis cas une forme de
voyeurisme on voit pourtant que chez nos
voisins d'europe du nord en suède en
finlande ça pose absolument pas de
problème est ce qu'on doit aller on doit
tendre vers ça écoutez moi
a priori je dirais que la vie privée
c'est quelque chose de sacré et ça vaut
pour vous pour moi pour tout un chacun
et aussi pour le personnel politique
donc c'est une première chose donc je
crois qu'il faut manier tout ça avec une
extrême prudence
ensuite je n'aime pas beaucoup qu'on
stigmatise la classe politique
or dans cette démarche il ya qu il ya
quelque chose d'un peu malsain et puis
j'aime pas beaucoup même si je n'en fais
pas partie
malheureusement qu'on stigmatise les
riches je trouve que c'est idiot
enfin parce que voilà vous avez bien vu
comment tout le monde a réagi en en
regardant la liste des ministres temps a
été regardée sur les plus riches alors
quoi comment ça se fait que enfin je
veux dire voilà je trouve que évidemment
que le personnel politique doit être
irréprochable mais on doit faire
attention à ne pas les populismes walla
walla parce que parce que c'est ça au
fond merci maroun labaki d'avoir analysé
pour nous ce qui se passe chez vos
voisins français nous on continue notre
petit tour d'europe
vous savez qu'en france en ce moment
nous mettons en place une réforme des
rythmes scolaires pour passer à quatre
jours et demi et notre modèle
semble-t-il c'est le modèle allemand
alors nous avons été en bavière pour
essayer de voir comment l'école
allemande fonctionne c'est un reportage
de mélanie bon temps et de paul bouffard
très tôt le matin c'est un ballet
d'écoliers qui s'activent en bavière
comme dans le reste du pays début de
journée à 7h40 pour les petits allemands
michael kraus est instituteur dans le
village de castle ici comme le veut la
tradition allemande
la classe est donné le matin ils
débutent leur journée avec des petits
jeux d'informatique
alors ici on commence le matin où
commence le matin à 7h40 les cours
durent environ 45 minutes
il y a deux pauses une première de 20
minutes à 9h10 puis une seconde un peu
plus tard les cours finissent
normalement aux alentours de 12h40
c'est ce système qui est aujourd'hui la
source d'inspiration du gouvernement
français dans sa réforme des rythmes
scolaires en allemagne
les élèves ont en moyenne 193 jours
d'école par an contre 140 en france
moins de vacances mais un rythme plus ou
avec moins d'heures de classe seulement
cinq par jour
au final c'est moins de fatigue pour les
écoliers et je pense que bien sûr quand
on doit rester à l'école jusqu'à midi et
qu'ensuite on retourne dans son
environnement familial on est peut-être
moins fatiguer le si on reste à l'école
jusqu'à 16 heures à l'école on ne peut
jamais vraiment se décontracter à castle
et dans la plupart des écoles
d'allemagne on compte en moyenne 21
élèves par classe
loukas 9 ans et en dernière année de
primaire d'abord on a allemand ensuite
pour demain mois après l'école je rentre
à la maison aujourd'hui j'ai match de
foot
l'après-midi le faire être dehors et
jouer avec mes amis
autre classe ici ses cours d'orthographe
avec reina strauss institutrice depuis
17 ans à cas cela en tant que professeur
l'après midi je peux travail est
corrigée et préparer mes cours pour les
prochains jours à 13 heures les jeunes
allemands filt à la garderie d'autres
vont en cours de musique ou encore aux
sports autre différence de taille avec
la france le salaire des professeurs ici
à munich en bavière un jeune instituteur
commence avec 2200 euros net par mois
1600 pour un français le système
éducatif est financé par les länder
régions pour les titres sur le statut la
participation à l'échelon national
comme tous les matins axel breun âge
prépare les enfants
une nouvelle journée d'école pour shirin
et noam le papa est français il vit en
allemagne depuis 15 ans ces enfants sont
nés et scolarisés ici à munich alors il
peut comparer ça leur laisse beaucoup de
temps beaucoup plus de temps pour faire
leurs devoirs ou pour ou pour simplement
aller à la bibliothèque ou pour un pur
pour en fait pour avoir la possibilité
d'apprendre par d'autres moyens
simplement que par l'école
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des enfants l'après-midi effectivement
quand les enfants n'ont pas d'école il
faut les occuper comme on travaille tous
les deux avec ma femme on arrive assez
on a réussi on a eu de la chance on a
réussi à avoir une place pour les deux
mais il ya beaucoup de gens
effectivement qu'ils sont obligés
finalement de travailler en mi temps ou
de ne pas travailler de ne pas
travailler pour pouvoir s'occuper de
leurs enfants l'après-midi en allemagne
la tradition est tenace et
particulièrement dans les länder de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est où la
maman reste à la maison pour élever ses
enfants dans plus de 50 % des couples
avec un enfant de moins de 6 ans seul
l'homme travaille donc pas facile de
gérer un emploi du temps avec ce rythme
scolaire vient justement beaucoup de nos
gens qui demandent des places en
garderie cas pas pour l'instant y'a pas
les infrastructures pour cent un modèle
jalousé par toute l'europe qui se remet
aujourd'hui en question le système
s'essouffle devant les inégalités
sociales du coup pourquoi pas une école
à temps plein c'est nécessaire pour deux
raisons tout d'abord c'est une
possibilité pédagogique
on dispose de plus en plus de temps pour
l'enseignement d'un autre côté il ya
tout simplement la réalité sociale mais
plus en plus de familles ont besoin de
cette possibilité de laisser leurs
enfants à l'école
toute la journée le nombre de femmes
actives augmente de plus en plus et je
pense que c'est une question d'emploi du
temps la journée complète à l'école est
une conséquence du développement du
travail et femmes
aujourd'hui les pédagogues allemands
restent satisfaits mais pour continuer à
garantir à la fois une bonne éducation
et l'emploi des femmes
l'allemagne doit remettre en cause ses
vieilles traditions depuis 2004 plus de
4 milliards d'euros ont été investis
pour permettre à un tiers des écoles
primaires d'offrir une journée de classe
à temps plein
c'était un portage de paul bouffard
tourné dans une école de bavière nous
sommes toujours au coeur du parlement
européen à strasbourg est notre invité
nous a rejoint jean marie cavada bonjour
merci d'être là vous êtes député
européen ancien président de radio
france et vous est notamment membre de
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation du parlement européen
à voir ce reportage on a l'impression
que tout va plutôt bien notamment dans
la petite ville allemande de castres le
la classe le matin comme la pratique
l'allemagne est ce que pour vous c'est
le modèle à suivre en europe
en tout cas c'est l'orientation qu'il
faut prendre il ya plusieurs choses
d'ailleurs qu'il faut dire tout ce qui
peut concourir à alléger une journée
mais a allongé le nombre de journées
d'école est une bonne chose
la france était avant la réforme peillon
dans un une moyenne de cent quarante
quatre jours après la réforme je crois
que ce sera à peu près 180 180 c'est une
moyenne européenne
7c'est ces 10 jours de moins que la
finlande et c'est 30 jours de moins que
le pays où il ya le plus d'écoles dans
une année qu'elle danemark mais en gros
180 jours c'est une bonne moyenne ce qui
permet quoi de mieux étaler les cours de
faire en sorte que les enfants ne soient
pas abrutis de fatigue et puis ensuite
perdu dans des vacances interminable
parce qu'il faudra bien s'attaquer au
deuxième volet qui est la durée des
vacances je crois comprendre que c'est
dans la tête de vincent peillon je pense
que dans ce domaine là il n'a pas que
des amis mais l'intérêt général passe
par dessus au dessus de l'intérêt du
tourisme et puis dans cet état jacobin
faut apprendre à faire ce que
l'allemagne fait c'est-à-dire
désarticulé en autorités régionales
la prise de décision des vacances par
exemple l'éducation nationale ça veut
pas dire ce que tout le monde est en
vacances partout en même temps c'est à
dire pas le cas en france sauf l'été
est-ce que ça crie que ces vacances est
une spécificité française parce que
quand on regarde les chiffres 12
semaines de vacances en espagne en
italie six semaines seulement pour les
écoliers aux pays bas en allemagne et ce
qu'on travaille plus au nord aussitôt
les bien évidemment oui bien sûr on
travaille il ya une relation l'espagne
l'italie et la france sont des pays
disons un peu gorgés de soleil
alors le tourisme a pris le pas et on
allait large du petit à petit va quand
je ne voudrais pas à faire un rappel
mais quand moi j'étais enfant les
vacances c'était après le 14 juillet et
l'école reprenait fin août ou au maximum
début septembre
donc c'était un mois et demi c'était
déjà très bien franchement et donc il ya
il ya un deuxième point c'est les
vacances d'été et un troisième point
qu'il faudra un jour atteindre
sérieusement c'est celui je dirais de
l'equilibre d'une journée aller
davantage vers ce que font les allemands
c'est à dire davantage de sport de
loisirs de divertissements de travaux
pratiques et d'accompagnement les gosses
ils ont besoin d'avoir un bon
enseignement et ils ont besoin d'avoir
aussi de quoi s'épanouir de la liberté
du sport pour soutenir l'attention des
très jeunes
il faut alterner les activités sur une
journée il faut pas avoir oui
naturellement tout le monde sait ça tous
les bals savent sachez que ils ont peut
pas donner huit heures de courant
continu à des bébés à des petits enfants
ça ne tient pas debout 1 et il ya une
dernière chose que je voudrais dire une
bonne réforme devrait aller jusqu'au
bout des choses c'est à dire améliorer
le salaire des enseignants de base il
faut le dire vous avez vu dans votre
reportage l'allemagne à s'il ya quand
même 600 euros de différence pour un
instituteur à équivalence mais bien
entendu que c'est important
bien entendu on évite la paupérisation
d'un métier puis ce sont des métiers qui
contrairement à ce qui se dit bien sûr
il ya beaucoup de vacances mais aussi
dans une journée
c'est dur il ya beaucoup de fatigue et
puis quand vous rentrez chez vous vous
avez aussi vos enfants ça n'a pas été
bien pensée de ça et puis petit à petit
on a calomnié l'éducation comme une
sorte de périmètre de privilégier tout
ça est absolument absurde
il faut que le gouvernement ait l'inter
et le sens de l'intérêt général et
brille cette affaire des vacances et à
faire des salaires progressivement parce
que je sais bien que les finances
publiques n'ont pas les moyens d'être
très prodigue en matière de financement
alors on dit que l'allemagne est souvent
cité en exemple en même temps la classe
le matin est un peu remis en cause
puisque se développe en allemagne des
activités l'après midi est ce qu'il faut
en raison notamment du
de l'adaptation nécessaire au travail
des femmes est ce qu'il faut adapter les
rythmes scolaires à l'évolution de la
réalité sociale et notamment au travail
des femmes
j'ai tendance à dire que le travail des
femmes posant problème comme autrefois
le travail des enfants dans les fermes
des agriculteurs inde en avant les
années 60 où les fermes qui n'est pas
d'argent avait besoin de bras c'était
les enfants moi même d'ailleurs quand
j'étais tout gamin élevé dans une ferme
des vosges
j'ai participé aux travaux de la ferme
et je pense qu'il faut quand même dans
la république de jules ferry dire une
chose très claire
l'éducation des enfants l'instruction
est l'éducation des enfants passent
avant toute autre considération sociale
ou économique il faut dire c'est
toujours l'intérêt de l'enfant fut
d'abord l'intérêt de l'inspiration c'est
après on verra le reste est pour vous
l'école de jules ferry a vécu
aujourd'hui ou quelle est sa première
mission finalement on va faire en sorte
non seulement n'a pas vécu mais il
faudra pratiquement rappeler les
principes il ya des il ya des familles
où les enfants ne vont pas à l'école
il ya des familles où les enfants vont à
l'école mais traverse sa est sorti en
très mauvais état
savent à peine lire savent à peine
compte et enfin bref et donc la mission
de l'école de jules ferry a à nouveau
beaucoup de sens et il faut s'armer pour
qu'elle soit efficace auprès de ses
enfants déclassé socialement qui
n'auront jamais destin social
intéressant et qui pour une partie
d'entre eux d'ailleurs on le voit bien
fondé délinquants par conséquent c'est
vraiment redevenu très important très
très importants et le modèle éducatif
européen il va plutôt bien
le modèle éducatif européen ne se porte
pas mal oui franchement franchement
en même temps quand on rentre dans les
couches supérieures c'est à dire je
pense notamment à l'enseignement
supérieur
ce modèle doit tendre à se rapprocher de
la réalité de la société c'est-à-dire de
l'économie de l'emploi ou aussi de
savoir garder ses chercheurs et ses
jeunes
ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est que
beaucoup de jeunes quittent l'europe
pour aller au mieux ils restent en
europe en grande bretagne mais pour
aller surtout dans d'autres continents
parce qu'ils trouvent que l'europe a
beaucoup vieilli il faut que l'europe se
reprenne en main y compris dans le
système éducatif faut développer
l'apprentissage faut développer
l'apprentissage en parallèle avec le
même degré de grades de gradation que
les études intellectuelle entre
guillemets bien entendu c'est très
important
est ce que pour vous actuellement le
système français est inégalitaire
je n'aime pas faire des chapelles ici
les terroriser mais vous savez dans
l'éducation il est toujours plus facile
pour les familles aisées de soutenir les
efforts des enfants que pour les
familles ça c'est une réalité que c'est
une réalité
alors moi j'ai vécu dans un système
n'ayant pas de famille du tout où la
bourse d'état a joué le rôle du soutien
que danic familiale je ne sais pas si
c'est encore il y en a beaucoup en cours
de bourse un je ne sais pas si c'est
toujours aussi efficace parce qu'une
bourse est pas suffisant il faut un
éducateur référent qui vous soutiennent
faut une personne un professeur x un
instituteur et ça je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure ça fonctionne je me méfie
quand même des schémas généraux et bien
merci jean marie cavada d'avant était
l'invité d'europe 1 dont vous laisse
retourner dans l'hémicycle où je vais
recruter un ou vous allez voter c'est
bien et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à bruxelles avec françois vos
données pour une autre émission d'europe
et de d'autray bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires